[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
i'm ca murray and i'm in the company of
my
fellow associate speaker pastor daniel
miranda pastor good to be with you as
always thank you it's always good to be
here
and it is good to have your questions to
answer we like to study the word of god
and so it gives us a chance to do some
things
that we like to do that is answer your
questions from the word of god and as
always we make you this promise
that whenever
you send in the question we will try our
very best to answer you from the word of
god we make you that promise that in
these latter days of the history of this
earth you don't need to hear the words
of men you need to hear a word from the
lord and that is what we promised to
give you if an answer can be found we
encourage you to send in your questions
to
tv
at some tv dot o r g that is t v at s u
m t v
dot o r g and we will add your questions
to the considerable list of questions
that we have now we like that that's not
a complaint we like the idea that there
are a lot of questions it means that
people are watching that they're being
blessed that they have questions their
questions are being answered so they're
sending in more uh we have in our little
pile here
about four or five questions from the
same person right so we're getting a lot
of questions we've got some regulars we
have some new individuals there are
certain names we look for periodically
because they come in and they have many
many questions so do join us by sending
in your questions we will answer them
from the word of god pastor if you would
pray we will launch out with our first
question for this particular program
absolutely let's pray dear heavenly
father as we open up your word and try
to answer the questions from your people
i pray that you may give us the wisdom
to know how to answer according to your
word in the name of jesus amen amen the
first question comes to us from jay or
ja
alex jay i don't know that's
initials like ca or it's ja
uh i've heard people call me car
occasionally i've been called calm many
many times
but this is from uh brother alex would
just say he's got two
let's go to second samuel chapter six
and the second samuel chapter eight
because both of his questions come from
the book of 2nd samuel 2nd samuel
chapter 6 and verse 16.
his first question is drawn from that
particular text and he's asking what was
the problem
here is it dancing is it music what is
the problem so we're in second samuel
and i'm turning over to chapter six
and looking at verse 16.
all right this is an interesting uh bit
of scripture
uh daniel do you want to take a stab i
don't want to read it for us if you will
sure i will
reading from the king james version the
bible says and the ark of the lord came
into the city of david
mikhail
saul's daughter looked through a window
and saw king david leaping and dancing
before the lord
and she despised him in her heart all
right if you have a new king james you
will see it as leaping and whirling
before the lord and she despised him in
her heart um you want to take a stab at
the answer because i've got one for for
this but i'll i'll do the honor of
letting the younger man go first oh
thank you well
i just have a very short
comment on this
when we read
in the spirit of prophecy what really
happened here
the reason i think the question is what
was the problem here dancing music
the problem why she despised him was
because she
because he laid off his royal garments
and rejoiced with the common people she
was jealous she was envious
um
previous verses i believe it says that
he took off his clothes
subversion said that he was naked but in
reality he was in common clothes
and then he he comes actually when
when we come
to verse
20 it tells us why mikhail was
upset
then they returned to bless his
household and mikhail the daughter of
saul
came out to meet david and said how
glorious was the king of israel today
who uncovered himself today in the eyes
of the handmaids of his servants as one
of the vain fellows
shamelessly uncovered
himself all right so her
her complaint here and this of course is
sarcasm except
she she's saying okay how glorious were
you today you know you exposed yourself
all the women were checking you out and
um you know you took off your clothes
and and of course he was not naked but
he had taken off his outer garments his
royal garments and
uh it was not dancing and and
the bible says he was leaping and
rolling of course this was a great day
uh the arc was was coming back you
remember that 20 plus years before the
ark was taken in battle hoffney and
phineas had passed
eli had passed um
the wife of hofney had passed a phineas
had passed and the ark was taken into uh
captivity the awkward should have never
been there because they were using it as
a talisman and it was never designed to
be used that way and so it was taken
from them
and there was a lot of sadness on the
day well that day is forgotten now the
ark is coming back david is leaping and
swirling and leaping and swirling and
he's he is dancing before the lord
michael did not like it now if you go to
the last
verse in that particular chapter you see
something that is very very important in
looking at this whole thing
verse 23 therefore michael
the daughter of saul had no children to
the day of her death therefore that is
given what happened given what she said
given how she responded
the the
crux of the matter
daniel my friend was
she rejected david's praise david was
praising the lord and he says so in
verse 21 it was before the lord uh who
chose me instead of your father now that
he's throwing a little brick at her you
know i'm the king not your dad who used
to be the king so he's kind of getting
back and forth and you've got this kind
of
servant volley they're going back and
forth at each other she's putting
something on him he's laying something
on her but the the problem is he was
praising the lord out of the goodness of
his heart out of joy he wasn't really
cognizant of what he was doing he wasn't
respecting what he was doing he was just
happy responding to the fact that the
art was come back coming back marco
rejected that you've got this little
servant volley he says something unkind
she says something unkind but she
rejected his praise and of course
the punishment was if we can use that
term therefore
michael the daughter of saul had no
children to the day of her death now if
you look at all of david's wives his
principal wives because he had
concubines but his principal he had
children with them all right even
uh
you know that little story with uh
naboth and you know a little thing where
he got abigail and you know there's all
kinds of things and he had children with
all of them
so
michael
his
first wife his you could say real wife
he had no children with her because of
this
so god uh and that's a pretty stiff
punishment to put on someone yeah but it
was because she rejected his his praise
right um
and there were things going on with
david and michael you know throughout
their relationship but she rejected his
praise so it wasn't the dancing it
wasn't even the music the the problem
here is rejecting the honest praise that
someone is giving giving and uh that was
the punishment that was given given to
michael uh she bore no children which is
in back in those days pretty stiff
punishment not to have any children and
the dancing here is not
some people may use this verse to say
that the bible condones dancing
but
this is not the kind of dancing
that
people practice today yes
this is more
joyous expression
of praise to the lord
i uh when i was in new york uh had
several close hebrew friends uh
including uh my eye doctor his father
was a rabbi and i had a chance to attend
service with
him on friday evenings many times we
became very close he was my doctor for
25 years
and we had discussions particularly he
loved it he liked to talk about daniel
he loved the book of daniel we'd get you
know contending about daniel but in
their services there is what you would
call a dance it is more of a pantomime
it is not the bumping and grinding that
you know we see today you know and it's
not done in mixed company you know
there's not men touching women women
touching men that kind of thing it's a
totally different
sort of expression of joy and that's
what's happening here so we're not
talking about the the boogie woogie or
the whatever you know kids are doing
today i have no idea you know you get
older you get out of those things so i
have no idea what even the dances are
called but it's not that this is
something totally different and um
michael should not have
rejected it in fact she should have
joined in the praise and the glory and
she did not and that was her her
punishment so uh good question
and um uh
well thought out but the problem is
neither dancing nor music it's praising
god and the rejection of that praise to
god yeah all right we go now to second
second samuel chapter eight and verse
two
just uh two chapters later chapter eight
and verse two and i'll take a stab at
this then
he defeated moab
forcing them
down to the ground
he measured them off
with a line
with two lines he measured off those to
be put to death
and with one
full line those who he those to be kept
alive so the moabites became david's
servants and
brought tribute
this is
something without equal
in in the old testament this is pretty
stark
um
the bible does not give us a lot of
understanding as to why david took such
severe measures but he he did
and we don't see this in david dealing
with
any other group or with any other group
in the bible that uh that i know of that
were under any direction from god now
the assyrians were much crueler than
this
practice cruelty as a way of of warfare
but as far as god's people are concerned
we don't see anything akin akin to this
yes
right
um and the question he asked did he kill
the adults here and let the children
live
do did he then have child slaves well
the bib the verse doesn't say anything
and we don't have any evidence from the
bible
in regards to who were killed or not
this is all we have here yeah the
moabites you could kind of be
look at them as as first cousins
of israel they are they're very closely
related uh moab and ammon being the kids
of um
of uh
um
more than ammon so so they're they're
very closely related um and there was an
interesting interplay between them all
moab comes up and more bites come up
again and again and again in their
social intercourse with israel so
they're always around so evidently
there's something that is not
particularly spelled out
here that was going on that caused david
to react like this david was pretty much
though he was a a a good warrior and a
great conqueror we don't see him being
evil or vindictive so this is out of
step with what we see classically as
david's activities this may be one of
the things we have to put on our bucket
list for asking the lord when we get to
heaven because the bible does not spell
it out
and i i saw in my glancing no particular
spirit of prophecy quotes that uh that
pertain to this particular text all
right so we've got we've got to wait on
this one uh alex and
and see what the lord has has to say
what's next uh daniel
we have a question from
jarielle aponte figueroa and we'll get
some more questions from him
um he's asking about
caffeine
we are seventh-day adventists we teach
that coffee is bad for your health
are there any
reliable sources you could recommend me
about this matter
i've tried to look it up on the internet
but all i can find everywhere is that
coffee is dangerous after a certain
number of cups
i want the truth especially since i love
someone who likes drinking coffee
frequently and it worries me quite a bit
to think
she is drinking poison and running her
nervous system
what about decaf coffee is it harmful
too
for years and i have not checked the
latest church manual
caffeine was mentioned in the
baptismal vows as something to avoid
they would say
coffee
teas
colas
and
certainly liquor
there are chemical substances in
coffee
that are injurious to the body
what's interesting nowadays you can buy
what's called a sports drink or a a shot
a little
bottle maybe just about this tall
of almost pure caffeine
you know the problem is when you when
you jack your body up on a substance
after a while the body's got to come
down and get rest so you pay for that
that high it's temporary
and then caffeine has long-term effects
uh
my wife years ago was having
lumps in her chest and uh pains in her
feet and the doctor said you got to get
off caffeine
and she did there was a little
withdrawal and
she was fine so it does have injurious
effects and it does have long-term
long-term effects
and when we
and it is true i was doing my research
for this question
and it is true that we don't find much
scientific support to what lmy says
about coffee
um recently there have been some studies
that prove what she says but still
compared to all the studies
that we have
most of them support
the use of coffee
but all comes back to
the source of the sources of authority
that we use as seven-day adventists now
in regards to decaf coffee
um i was doing i was doing some research
and the cafe nation
uses chemicals like
methylene chloride
that are not good for your health either
there are some healthier options some
people might not
think that that's quite the same
but there's some cereal coffee
that we can use
back in in my country in colombia there
is a someone who takes the okra seeds
roast them and he makes coffee out of it
and it's very delicious that is the
closest coffee to real coffee coffee
that i've ever tried before and it's
very nice coffee the coffee made of okra
seeds
and you can roast them and it's pretty
easy you grind them
[Music]
but rye coffee and or rice cereal and
there are many other options yeah they
have a coffee in panama my wife's
country uh
this is my first hearing of okra seeds i
don't know what that coffee is made of
maybe it's corn and something else but
there are all kinds of coffee
substitutes that are healthier
for you
the thing is we have we've become so
accustomed
accustomed to stimulants
in our diet there are those who can
cannot really get up in the morning
without one two cups of coffee a couple
cups of coffee during the day then they
cannot wind down at night because their
body is so uh in gear that they can't
sleep so it's up down up down up down
and falsely stimulating your your body
uh
is is is
bad for your long-term health sure it's
not going to value anything i would
recommend jarielle that you go to
councils on diet and food and also the
book temperance by ellen white
and she has a lot to say there about
coffee and its effects and why is it
harmful to our bodies
very good
i remember the first time i went through
councils and diets and foods
and uh
it uh it does me work its way into your
pantry and uh and
take out a lot of things you know but
the thing is a lot of things that we eat
you know
there are several adventist doctors and
and many health practitioners who will
tell you that we need to look at food as
medicine
that
if we're eating something we ought to
get the the best we can the most healthy
things we can and eat real food there
are a lot of things that are engineered
food that are not real food they don't
really satisfy so you've got to eat a
lot of it you're taking a lot of
calories and they don't do anything for
you
most fast food is not good food it's
just fast food right if you develop a
taste for fast food you probably will
not like real food
if you develop a taste for eating a lot
of meat
ellen white talks about this the first
time she moved into vegetarianism she
came down to the table no meat on the
table and so she said you know what i'm
not hungry went back upstairs so later
she came out for the next meal no meat
on the table
ah no i'm not hungry so the next day she
said you know i'm gonna eat this food or
i'm going to eat nothing at all and she
developed a taste for it by training her
taste buds
there's sugar in almost everything sugar
is in ketchup sugars and mustard sugar
it's everything has some sugar so we're
getting tons and tons of sugar um i had
a friend who used to drink a buy a 64
ounce cup of uh of soda that's a
pharmaceutical dosage of no one should
take that much sugar in a day let it on
at one drink you know a couple of days
worth uh so that does things to your
body into your health and uh you cannot
serve the lord as you should when your
body is beaten up so so there are a lot
of things that we need to be very very
careful about because they don't help
and caffeine is one of them to be found
in
in coffee
very good all righty
all right is this one this is
matthew 26
let's see
ma at the end i think it's a brother
from china from china yes a blessing too
yes yes from china
dear pastor blessings to you and your
ministry
um
he comments on the sermon the sermon on
mercenary disciples
and the study comes from matthew 26 2016
and 27. closely i found a chinese
version of verse 26
which shows jesus
blessing the bread
uh
and if he says he gave thanks
well verse 27 says jesus gave thanks
although the estee bible congress says
that the bread
and the agape juice both mean his body i
still cannot get myself convinced
for bread and cup are treated as the
same
may i reckon the bread as his body
the cup
as the sin of the world
with his ceiling
so
as they are different jesus didn't give
thanks for his own body that is his
character so i guess he wants an
explanation on the bread
and the wine right okay
uh
what say
well the verse itself makes it very
clear uh he's quoting from matthew 26
verse 26 and 27
and the verse itself makes it very clear
that jesus when he referred to his b to
bread
he was referring to his body and when
jesus referred to wine
he was referring to his blood to his
blood yeah that's up i think he's mixing
up a little bit here the cup
actually the cup is not the big thing
here is what is in the cup it's in the
cup very much so the wine
so um
they
both represent jesus's life
shed on the cross
for us now in the second paragraph
he
he makes the difference between giving
thanks
and
and blessing
well that doesn't really make much of a
difference
um
why he asked why
he blessed
the bread but when it comes to wine he
didn't bless the wine he just gave
thanks
to the wine
well the word blessed in the greek is
eulogio and the the word for tanks is
eukarystelle
the eologio means bless or bless your
blessings and thanks means you carry
still
when we go to luke 22 17 and 19 the same
parallel passage
we see jesus using the word el caristeo
for both
the bread and the wine so
that accent that doesn't make any
difference i mean he is blessing both
and giving thanks for both bread and
wine because i represent his body his
death on the cross
there there are many texts that sort of
work this out for us in first
corinthians chapter 11 verse verse in
verse 25
um
we see those texts that we use so very
often at
communion services and
christ makes the statement that
after the same manner took the cup and
he says that this is the new testament
well let me just read it rather than
coming from my memory uh unless you have
it there already while i'm turning
um
first corinthians do you have it down
here or not yeah i think i do yeah okay
verse
23 and 24 for i have received of the
lord that which also i delivered unto
you the lord jesus the same night in
which he was betrayed to bread and when
he had given thanks so it's we read hear
that he gave thanks
for the bread he break it and said take
eat this is my body which is broken for
you
this is doing remembrance of me after
the same manner also he took the cuff
when he had sobbed saying this cup is
the new testament in my blood
this do ye
as often as you drink it in remembrance
of me
for as often as you eat of this bread
and drink of this cup
you do show the lord's death till he
come so both bread and wine represent
jesus's death yes yes
one his body the other's blood now
there's a third set of circumstances to
be found in john chapter 6
uh you you've almost got to read the
whole chapter and it's long because
you've got 66 verses there
and he says i'm the bread of life now in
john around about john 6 14
after the feeding of the 5000 they want
to make him king they want to force him
to be king he was picking up followers
right and left of course they were
following him for the fishes and the
lows they were following him because of
what they could get from him
when he explained
that
i didn't come to be king i came to
sacrifice
i came to sacrifice my body that you
have to eat my body
the bible says and ellen white backs
this up that there are many who were
turned off by that and in john 6 66 it
says from that time many of his
disciples went back and walked with him
no more
um because that that's not what they
wanted they didn't want to eat my my
body and drink my blood they wanted get
rid of the romans make us number one put
us on top and not the bottom uh so they
left him and
ellen white says that many of those who
left at that time their decisions
uh were never more reversed they never
came back again which means they died in
their sins
that that rejection was the unpardonable
sin for them and they died in their sins
so it's a very very important text
because it sealed the fate of many who
chose to walk away from christ and
that's it that decision was never turned
back again so um
i think your point is well taken that uh
the blood the blood
and the body of christ are symbolized in
the communion experience and the
blessing and the praying for are pretty
much interchangeable they are the same
thing and uh so christ is consistent
throughout and uh the what
the way he he handled that service and
what he had to say was consistent
throughout
so it's very clear i wouldn't say
that the cup as he puts it here the cup
he says the cup represents the scene of
the world with his ceiling
i wouldn't say
that when jesus the verses that he
quotes from matthew 20 and 22 and
matthew 26 39 and 44
the cup in this context is is different
from the cup that he was giving during
the lord's supper the cup here was the
the suffering that jesus was going to go
through
the cup of his father's wrath yes but it
was not we cannot say that
that cup is the same cup
that jesus gave to his disciples in
communion service again as we always say
when you're reading the word of god
context means so very very much and how
a particular word is defined
is determined by the context in which it
finds itself again
a number of great questions please send
in your questions we'll do our best to
answer them until then god bless you
we'll see you again soon bye
[Music]
you